I'm sorry Jade bows I'm a lecturer in
discipline at Columbia University's
School of Continuing Education and the
Earth Institute what you're about to see
is a set of three lectures on the
mathematical essentials necessary to go
through our master of science in
sustainability management program this
is the second of three sessions today
we're going to talk about slopes and
derivatives which is basically calculus
we'll talk about univariate calculus for
quite a while which is calculus related
to functions of single variables and
then we'll get to multivariate calculus
and okay let's I'll just give you a
quick overview here we ended last week
or we ended in the last session talking
about slopes of linear functions today
we're going to start speaking about
slopes of nonlinear functions which will
take us into calculus and the first and
second derivatives are methods of
computing the slopes or actually by
definition the slopes of a function will
talk about concavity and convexity which
are properties that you'll need to
understand in order to use calculus for
practical applications then there is a
large section on rules of
differentiation some of you may have
come through the slides that I sent out
this afternoon and there's probably
a third of the slides are on rules of
differentiation we will spend a little
time going through them and doing some
examples but you don't need to learn the
rules of differentiation they're there
to help you when you need them but in
general the point today and also the
point in other classes that you'll take
in the program is to understand what the
rules are for when you might need them
who to ask if you need to use them and
not necessarily actually to use them
yourself okay but you know if you are if
you want to know about how to use a tool
even though you might not have to use it
too often you do need to use it once or
twice to get a sense of what it is then
we'll talk about maximization and
minimization which are of course the key
practical applications of calculus and
there will do some examples and then
we'll talk about multivariate calculus
okay okay everybody ready calculus is
about calculus is a method that
facilitates speaking compactly about
slopes of nonlinear functions you saw
earlier that linear functions have very
simple slopes they have constant slopes
nonlinear functions by definition do not
have constant slopes their slopes change
as the value of x the input variable
changes because they change things get a
little more complicated but calculus is
a mat is a set of shorthand tools to
allow us to deal with changing slopes
that's all it is so if you are asked in
future why do we care about calculus
what is calculus it's simply a set of
shorthand to
tools to help you deal with the varying
slopes of nonlinear equations okay by
definition the slope of a nonlinear
equation at a particular value of x at a
particular value of the input variable
is the slope of the tangent line to the
function at that point okay or to be
more precise the slope of the tangent
line to the function at the value at
that point so let's put X here in the
last session I referred to the vertical
axis is why okay often we'll also refer
to it as f of X okay so this is the
independent variable this is the
dependent variable the function of X and
this curve is a graph and remember what
the graph is anybody want to tell us
what a graph of a function is
okay so you're close it's a line that
connects all pairs of points X comma f
of X that satisfy the functional
relationship between the two or that
satisfy the equation that describes the
functional relationship between the two
so this is the graph of a function so
every point on this line or on this
locus satisfies the functional
relationship between X and Y or the
function of X okay now if I take a point
an arbitrary point let's say X star from
all these possible values of the
independent variable and I ask well
what's the value of the function at that
point ok so this and it might help to
think of X as something particular let's
say if you are concerned with yields
this could be fertilizer input and this
could be yield per hectare
okay this value will calling f of X star
okay so this could be 10 pounds of
fertilizer per square meter and this
could be certain number of bushels of
corn let's say okay at that point this
point has the Cartesian coordinates X
star f of X star okay in the last
session I might have referred to this
point as 23 let's say okay now the
tangent line to the function is the line
is the straight line would just touches
the function at just that point and
nowhere else or nowhere else nearby okay
and of course since this is a straight
line it has a constant slope and that
constant slope is by definition the
slope of f of X at X star but if i took
some other point instead of x star if I
took some other point let's say X hat
then the function has a slightly
different slope okay in this case at X
hat is the function steeper or shallower
than at X star steeper right so this
function is getting steeper as x
increases okay yes so the this tangent
is a straight line it has a constant
slope that slope the the number the
constant number that you get
that number is the slope of the function
f of X at X star there's a different
number that is the slope of the function
f of X at X hat now yes the x star
that's a good question the X star is a
particular value of x from all possible
values of X for example you know it this
might have been the number two okay so
that this is a good question because you
want to clear this up and it's a very
common a very common point of confusion
X is a variable for example as you said
fertilizer input to the concept it's a
measurable concept right that's X X star
on the other hand is a number that
describes a particular value of that
concept so X you can think of as
fertilizer in put an X star could be two
pounds of fertilizer input per square
meter the number two would represent X
star and indeed you know if it would be
far less confusing if instead of saying
X star and X hat I use the number 2 for
X star and the number 3 for X hat but I
want you to go beyond the specific
numbers because of course when you do
this analysis it could be any number and
input not only could it be any number
but in particular you will be doing
analysis when you don't actually know
the types of numbers that might be in
so that's why that's the leap that you
have to make now okay or or it is part
of this process okay and just to address
that question a little bit further f of
X is a conceptual quantity such as yield
per hectare that is measurable f of X
star is a particular number of yield per
hectare for example this could be four
bushels of corn per hectare okay if your
functional relationship says that by
putting in two units of fertilizer you
get four bushels of corn then X star
would be 2 and f of X star would be four
ok now the tangent line of course as we
just said passes through X f of X now
here I had said X star comma f of X star
to denote a particular point now what I
want you to do is to imagine see I told
you that when I increase X from X star
to X hat the function gets steeper so
you know from the last session that when
the slope gets steeper what's happening
to the number that describes the slope
it's going up right it's increasing okay
so in this case when I go from X star to
X hat the slope of the function is going
to increase if I go from X hat to X star
the slope of the function will decrease
the slope of the function is itself
dependent on X
okay so that's a key insight that you
want to take away if that calculus uses
that is for a nonlinear function the
slope of that nonlinear function is
itself a function of X that's not the
case for a linear function in a linear
function the slope of the linear
function is just a constant okay so here
I drew a tangent line at a particular
point X star f of X star and on the
screen I've called this point X f of X
because of course that X star could be
anywhere this there could be an X star
here there could be an X star here there
could be a next are here and so on so
you can think of any of these points as
being collections of points X and f of X
and you could draw a tangent at any of
those points and that tangent would have
a slope okay so now if I wanted to
describe for this nonlinear function if
I wanted to describe the slope at every
point I could sit down and draw lots of
tangent lines and compute the slope and
people did that three thousand years ago
actually people did that four hundred
years ago okay and you know and it's not
nothing to be laughed at because all
sorts of insights were derived even from
that type of work right I mean people
worked out that the world was round just
from doing that without calculus okay
but the
but now suppose that we want a more
compact way of analyzing the
relationship between X and the slope
okay well you know what you could do
since you learnt about different ways to
construct functions last time you could
compute lots of different values of x
the associated slopes along the values
using the tangents put it in a table and
graph it okay and what do you think the
graph of a function that gives you the
slope of this function for different
values of x what do you think that would
look like yes you what's your name sorry
desirae yes of course okay a line
beginning at 0 slipping up but perhaps
you could tell your colleagues what
makes you say that like that
okay so Desiree is absolutely right at
actually it doesn't necessarily it
doesn't have to start at the origin it
could it could look like this okay yeah
we just we don't we don't know what
happens to the function out here but
clearly this is a function that slopes
upwards which means it has positive
slope here at there's some point where
it we think that it might be flat that's
the point where Desiree says the slope
of that function is going to be zero and
as x increases it gets steeper which
means the slope gets higher now why do
you think that this is a straight line
going up sorry it doesn't change
actually we don't really know that it's
a straight line given what I've told you
it could for example for it not to have
an inflection point it could sort of go
like that or it could go like that we
just don't know whether what will happen
further out but there's a good chance
that it could be a straight line okay
and in practical applications especially
with complex nonlinear functions often
we have to look at a small set of
parameters a small set of changes in the
either the dependent or independent
variable you know so if you think of
climate
change models large generalized climate
models oh you know that couple let's say
atmospheric processes and ocean
processes they don't generally have
built into it a functional relationship
for the entire range of parameters so if
you think of what's the current
concentration of carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere anybody know yes that we do
around yay around 400 392 let's say so
those models don't know what will happen
if carbon dioxide concentrations were at
10 or at 600 they simply have some
expectation they have some expectation
of what we'll do around the value 400
and they might extrapolate slopes beyond
that value in either direction but they
have they're not designed to understand
the nonlinearities beyond the range that
it observes okay so that's that's a very
common feature of environmental analysis
or indeed any kind of mathematical
analysis ok this is you're probably
wondering why I put this up the the
reason this is up is so that you now you
have a sense okay from looking at this
function this nonlinear function how its
slope might look okay as I said you
could work out the slope at every point
tabulate the results draw a new growth
now suppose you don't want to deal with
graphs graphs a cumbersome to deal with
and you can't do mathematical
calculations with them and this is why
you would need to use calculus so
essentially the elements of calculus
then proceeds from the following
reasoning it says okay that process that
iterative process which I talked about
before where I compute different values
of x and find the tangent and work out
the slope let's try to describe that
process in a mathematical way I have the
same nonlinear function the heavy black
line the heavy black curve I can draw a
tangent line at the point f of X start
as before and in addition to this
tangent line I could draw a secant line
the secant line is a straight line
connecting the inside part of a curve so
I can draw a secant line from this point
f of X star to some other point f of x
star plus Delta Delta represents the
distance between this point here and
that point it's a it's a change in X
suppose I increase X from X star 2 x
star plus delta i compute the value of
the function up here and i draw a
straight line there yes
the Q what's random is the Delta that I
chose okay I I pick an increment over X
star and I go to some other higher value
of x I picked that Delta at random let's
say and then once I picked that Delta
then I find out what's the function at
that value x star plus delta and that's
the cue and i could draw the secant line
here okay now i can work out the slope
of the secant line probably how would I
do that that's a straight line you
probably know how to work out the slope
of the straight line it's a little bit
different from the tangent line so what
how would I do that anybody want to take
a guess I right so nothing it says okay
we have two points P and Q here it's X
star and f of X star and here it's x
star plus delta and f of x star plus
delta right so i could work out that
slope that slope is going to be higher
than the slope of the tangent line now
suppose that I were to reduce the size
of Delta so instead of having an x star
plus delta out here i had an x star plus
delta somewhere in between i could
iterate that process again compute a new
value for the function here and instead
of the secant line that I've shown there
there's going to be another secant line
from P to some point like this the slope
of that secant line is going to be
closer to the slope of the tangent line
agreed okay so just a second so if i
were to iterate this process so that i
had infinitesimally smaller values of
Delta
the secant line would get closer and
closer to the tangent line okay and
mathematically the derivative is and is
a function that tells you what the limit
of the slope of the secant line is as
Delta gets smaller and smaller and the
key inside of calculus is understanding
that there is such a limit in many
situations and that that that limit can
be expressed by a mathematical formula
not just by iteratively writing down
slopes and associating slopes with
values of x okay okay so you know so
this is just to give you a sense of the
construction of the derivative you don't
have to worry about this you don't have
to worry too much about what this really
means but if it if you like the notion
of how a derivative is constructed
through this infinitesimal reduction in
the value of Delta so that the secant
line gets closer and closer to the
tangent line it might be nice to think
about how it's constructed here this is
just what nazanin told us earlier this
is the slope this is the formula for the
slope of the secant line ok this is the
rise over the run the run is just Delta
and the slope of the tangent line is
simply the limit of this as Delta goes
to zero okay
and the key insight of calculus is
realizing that that limit can be
formulaic Lee expressed for lots and
lots of equations lots and lots of
functions that we deal with okay
everybody with me at least at the sort
of 10,000 foot level okay just what
remember what I want you to get out of
this is to be able to explain to your
grandmother if she is not mathematically
inclined my grandmother was that what
the point of calculus is and what it's
all about okay